>>> THERE IS WORD TONIGHT THAT
THE MAYOR OF A KHARKIV AREA TOWN
HAS BEEN RELEASED.
SEVERAL DAYS EARLIER, YOU MAY
REMEMBER RUSSIANS GRABBED
MELITOPOL'S MAYOR.
THAT IS THEM, YOU SEE AT THE TOP
OF YOUR SCREEN.
HUSTLING HIM AWAY.
HE WAS FREED JUST YESTERDAY IN A
PRISONER SWAP ACCORDING TO
OFFICIALS.
AND GAVE HIS FIRST ENGLISH
LANGUAGE INTERVIEW TO US TODAY.
SPOKE TO HIM EARLIER AND YOU
WILL SEE THE VIDEO CONNECTION
WAS AT TIMES HIT AND MISS BUT WE
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR YOU TO
HEAR WHAT HE HAD TO SAY.
>> MAYOR FEDEROV, WHAT HAPPENED
WHEN YOU WERE ABDUCTED?
WHERE WERE YOU AND WHAT DID THEY
DO?
>> THEY TOLD ME ON THE MELITOPOL
POLICE IN SMALL ROOM.
IN ROOM FOR BAD BOYS.
AND THEY HELD ME TILL SIX DAYS
AND SHOW ME THAT THEY HAVE
GREATEST POWER, THEY HAVE
GREATEST ARMY.
MANY SOLDIERS WITH GUNS AND THEY
ASK ME STOP MEETING IN
MELITOPOL.
FROM PEOPLES WHO WANT TO LEAVE
IN UKRAINE BUT NOT IN RUSSIA
FEDERATION.
THEY WANT ME TO STOP MEETINGS.
THEY WANT ME -- THAT I SUPPORT
HIM TO MAKE RUSSIAN FEDERATION
IN MELITOPOL BUT I SAY NO, I
CAN'T DO.
>> WAS IT RUSSIAN SOLDIERS WHO
TOOK YOU?
>> YES, MANY SOLDIERS TALK WITH
ME.
NOT ONLY SOLDIERS BUT SPECIAL
SECRET SERVICES AGENT.
>> HOW DID THEY TREAT YOU?
DID THEY -- WERE THEY -- DID
THEY HURT YOU?
DID THEY YELL AT YOU?
HOW DID THEY TREAT YOU?
>> NO, NO, NO.
THEY LEAVE ME WITHOUT ANY
CONNECTIONS.
SO THEY LEAVE ME WITHOUT ANY IN
THE NEXT ROOM POLICE THEY BEAT
SOME AND, YOU KNOW, IT'S VERY
DANGEROUS SITUATION.
>> YOU -- AFTER YOU WERE
ARRESTED, CITIZENS IN YOUR TOWN
PROTESTED IN THE STREETS CALLING
FOR YOUR RETURN.
DID YOU KNOW THAT WAS HAPPENING?
DID YOU KNOW THAT PEOPLE WERE
PROTEST SOMETHING PROTESTING?
>> NO, I DON'T KNOW ANYTHING
BECAUSE I WAS WITHOUT CELL
PHONE, WITHOUT INTERNET, WITHOUT
ANY INFORMATION.
I DON'T KNOW IT.
>> A PROSECUTOR IN THE LUHANSK
REGION BACKED BY RUSSIA SAID
THAT YOU WERE GOING TO BE TRIED
FOR TERRORISM CHARGES.
WERE YOU TOLD THAT?
>> NO, I DON'T KNOW -- NO.
OF COURSE -- OF COURSE -- NOT
BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW ANY
TERRORISTS ORGANIZATION IN
UKRAINE.
AND OF COURSE, I DIDN'T GIVE
ANYTHING ELSE FOR HIM.
IT'S -- IT'S A JOKE.
IT'S NOTHING.
>> PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY SAID YOUR
KIDNAPPING WAS A CRIME AGAINST
DEMOCRACY.
THERE ARE OTHER UKRAINIAN
OFFICIALS IN OTHER CITIES WHO
HAVE REPORTEDLY BEEN KIDNAPPED
AS WELL.
IS THIS WHAT IS GOING TO HAPPEN?
IS THIS RUSSIA'S PLAN IN CITIES
THEY CONTROLLED?
>> OF COURSE IT'S RUSSIAN PLAN
BECAUSE MANY MY COLLEAGUES AND
ARE NOW IN THE SAME SITUATION.
AND NOW, WE TRY TO HELP THEM BUT
OF COURSE IT'S RUSSIAN PLAN
BECAUSE I AND MY COLLEAGUES
ELECTED MAYORS AND ELECTED BY
OUR CITIZENS.
THAT'S WHY THEY WANT TO PUSH US.
THEY WANT TO MAKE US IN A
DANGEROUS SITUATION AND THEY
WANT TO SHOW US THEIR POWER.
OF COURSE, IT'S THEIR PLAN, YES.
>> WERE YOU WORRIED?
WERE YOU SCARED WHEN YOU WERE
TAKEN?
>> UH, OF COURSE I'M -- OF
COURSE IT WAS SCARY.
BUT -- BUT I NEED TO DO BECAUSE
MY CITIZENS ELECTED ME AND I
MUST SHOW THEM THAT WE MUST HELP
OUR CITIZENS AND THEY ELECTED ME
AS A MAYOR FROM DEMOCRACY
UKRAINE CIVILIAN COUNTRY.
>> YOU WERE RELEASED UKRAINIAN
OFFICIALS SAY FOR NINE RUSSIAN
CAPTURED SOLDIERS.
THERE WAS AN EXCHANGE AND
PRISONERS.
DID YOU -- DID YOU KNOW THAT
WAS -- WAS -- WAS TAKING PLACE?
DID THEY JUST LET YOU GO?
>> YES.
I -- I WAS -- NINE SOLDIERS.
IT'S VERY YOUNG SOLDIERS BUT I
THINK THAT AGE -- IT DON'T TAKE
ANY INFORMATION BECAUSE THE
SOLDIERS COME TO OUR COUNTRY TO
KILL OUR CHILDRENS, TO KILL OUR
WOMENS, TO KILL OUR CIVILIAN
PEOPLES IN UKRAINE.
THAT'S WHY SOLDIERS COME TO
UKRAINE TO KILL AND IT'S THE
SOLDIERS.
IT'S NOT YOUNG PEOPLES.
>> A REPLACEMENT MAYOR WAS
APPOINTED BY -- BY RUSSIAN
FORCES.
THEY'VE TAKEN DOWN THE UKRAINIAN
FLAG.
THEY TRIED TO DISBAND THE CITY
COUNCIL.
WHAT HAPPENS TO YOU NOW?
>> YES, IT'S WAS BECAUSE
UKRAINIAN FLED BECAUSE MELITOPOL
IS UKRAINIAN CITY.
BUT WHEN THEY WAS HOLD ME ON
SECOND DAY, THEY PUT DOWN THE
UKRAINIAN FLAG ON CENTRAL SQUARE
OF MELITOPOL AND THEY SHOW THEIR
POWER FOR ALL CIVILIAN PEOPLES
IN MELITOPOL.
NOW, IN DANGEROUS SITUATION
BECAUSE WE HAVE MANY
HUMANITARIAN CORRIDORS.
THERE ARE LESS FOOD IN
MELITOPOL, LESS PHARMACY, AND
MANY MEDICAL PROBLEMS.
OUR TEAM NOW DON'T WORK IN
MELITOPOL BECAUSE RUSSIAN
FEDERATION, RUSSIAN SOLDIERS ARE
FULLY CONTROL THIS SITUATION.
BUT AS I SPOKE WITH PRESIDENT
ZELENSKYY, HE [ INAUDIBLE ]
MELITOPOL AGAIN WILL BE
UKRAINIAN CITY AS ALL CITIES IN
UKRAINE WAS ANNEXED BY RUSSIAN
FEDERATION.
>> SO, WHAT WILL YOU DO NOW?
WHERE DO YOU GO?
>> PRESIDENT GIVE ME TASKS.
NOW, I WILL WORK IN
ZAPORIZHZHIA.
AND THE ZAPORIZHZHIA.
AND MAKE ALL TASK THAT GIVE ME
PRESIDENT.
>> WHAT IS YOUR MESSAGE TO -- TO
THE UKRAINIAN CITIZENS IN
MELITOPOL?
>> YOU KNOW, I HAVE MESSAGES NOT
FOR UKRAINIAN PEOPLES IN
MELITOPOL.
I HAVE MESSAGE FOR ALL WORLD.
ALL WORLD, EUROPEAN, U.S. WORLD
MUST TO UNDERSTAND THAT IT IS
NOT FAR FROM UKRAINE AND RUSSIA
FEDERATION.
AND MUST UNDERSTAND IF UKRAINE
CAN'T WIN THIS WAR, RUSSIA
FEDERATION STOPS WAR WITH
EUROPE, WITH MANY COUNTRIES OF
EUROPE.
IT'S WHY WE MUST BE TOGETHER
WITH -- YOU MUST BE TOGETHER ON
THIS WAR AND WE MUST, TOGETHER,
[ INAUDIBLE ] RUSSIA FEDERATION.
>> FINALLY, WHAT IS YOUR MESSAGE
TO RUSSIAN TROOPS?
YOUR MESSAGE TO VLADIMIR PUTIN?
>> THEY MUST UNDERSTAND THAT WE
DON'T WANT ANYTHING FROM RUSSIA
FEDERATION.
WE HAVE OUR COUNTRY.
OUR DEMOCRACY COUNTRY.
AND WE DON'T WANT SOMETHING FROM
RUSSIA FEDERATION.
AND THINGS THAT RUSSIA
FEDERATION MUST NOT WANT
ANYTHING FROM UKRAINE.
THAT'S WHY I THI